[Aplausos]
[Música]
e
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
a mí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ángel méndez montoya
ángel méndez montoya es danzante
bailarín de danza contemporánea obvio ya
lo vimos coreógrafo también novio ya lo
vimos pero quizás lo que no hemos visto
es que es filósofo
- lo hemos visto como teólogo e
inimaginable mente es religioso dominico
de la iglesia católica
y lo que acabamos de ver
paradójicamente no es una danza no es
una coreografía propiamente sino que es
una ponencia biológica que es lo que
vimos
bueno si es una ponencia teológica desde
el cuerpo basado o inspirado en un
pasaje evangélico bastante crudo un
pasaje que muy pocas veces nosotros le
ponemos atención oa veces la misma
iglesia lo ha borrado de la historia
porque es un pasaje bastante cruel donde
jesús sale muy mal parado en qué
evangelio usted está en evangelio de
mateo en el capítulo 15 el versículo del
21 al 28 para aquellos que saben la
biblia y es un pasaje muy crudo porque
se trata de una mujer en cananea una
mujer canán y está que para los
israelitas
es una mujer forastera
y jesús va caminando por las calles y
esta mujer se le aproxima gritándole
pidiendo milagro para su hija que está
endemoniada y jesús en lugar de hacerle
caso en lugar de cumplir el milagro como
en otras ocasiones más bien le responde
una manera bastante cruel bastante
grosera que le dice le dice no está bien
quitarle el pan a los hijos de israel y
dárselo a los perros
entonces es una una frase muy fuerte uno
se esperaría que la mujer se fuera
llorando se fuera esconder y sin embargo
ella se impone y lo reta y le dice sí
señor pero aún los perros comemos las
migajas que caen de la mesa de los
señores
y en ese momento jesús abrió sus ojos y
dijo mujer qué grande es tu fe que se
cumpla según tú lo deseas y en ese
momento su hija fue sanada
este es un texto clave para lo que se
conoce como teología queer y tú has
desarrollado te has desempeñado como
doctor en teología haciendo producción
de teología queer también en forma
escrita porque es este texto en concreto
donde más podemos sentir no solamente un
pasaje queer sino a un jesús que tú
mismo has dicho que jesús se hace queer
si primero jesús estaba como ser humano
regularmente lo vemos como una persona
divina pero como ser humano tenía muchas
cosas que aprender y abrir sus
horizontes él como hombre en una
sociedad patriarcal
como israelita en una sociedad de la
suprema y de una supremacía bastante
xenófoba donde discriminan a los otros
los que están del otro lado y es ella la
mujer la que le enseña él y le abre el
horizonte la teología queer como ustedes
saben el término queer viene de la
palabra en inglés que significa raro
extraño extravagante pero también es una
palabra que se ha usado de forma
despectiva para discriminar a aquellas
personas que pertenecen a la comunidad
de la sexualidad diversa a la comunidad
lgbttti entonces es una palabra que se
ha usado para
peyorativamente para estigmatizar a
aquellas personas que están fuera de los
roles y de las normas heterosexuales
fuera de las normativas heterosexuales o
fuera de la heteronormatividad pero pero
es curioso creciendo eso el el origen de
la palabra extravagante o queer una vez
que vemos tu trabajo como coreógrafo una
vez que vemos esta propuesta dancística
y teológica a la vez en el pasaje es una
mujer
en el pasaje es una mujer y desde esta
interpretación haces a la misma mujer y
a todas las mujeres también parte de la
extravagancia y así es lo que tiene el
lado lo queer es que resignifica le da
la vuelta es un twist entonces lo queer
es aquello que aún siento obteniendo un
significado se resignifica la comunidad
lgbt en los momentos de los años 70
cuando salieron las calles en las
marchas del orgullo gay ellos gritaban
yo soy queer y estamos aquí así es que
ni modo acostúmbrense we are here and we
are queers get you street entonces lo
interesante de lo queer es que le da
tuerce los significados y resignifica
aquello que en un momento fue algo
peyorativo es aquello se que se
convierte en un estandarte de orgullo
entonces también en esta en este pasaje
bíblico vemos exactamente este
movimiento de twist este movimiento que
y los roles regularmente es jesús el que
es el protagonista en los evangelios y
aquí es la mujer la que es la
protagónica de este pasaje regularmente
es jesús el que vaya atiende a los
necesitados y es ella la que le exige a
él que la atienda regularmente jesús es
el maestro que enseña y que abre los
horizontes y aquí es ella la que le
enseña el para que abra sus horizontes
yo creo que el milagro primero ocurre en
jesús jesús abre su visión y entonces se
da cuenta de sus propios prejuicios de
sus propios muros que ha construido y él
es el primero que rompe esos muros y es
ella la que construye precisamente los
puentes en estas sesiones de ted hemos
estado hablando acerca de construir
puentes y nos hemos concentrado en el
tema de género en el tema de la
diversidad sexual en el tema no
únicamente de género y diversidad sexual
sino todos aquellos que están
la periferia todos aquellos que viven en
la diáspora que viven en los guetos de
la sociedad no solamente la diversidad
sexual sino también los migrantes los
pobres los indígenas aquí en méxico por
ejemplo personas que son los nativos de
estas tierras originarios de estas
tierras son los que sistemáticamente han
sido discriminados y siguen siendo
marginados en sus propias tierras como
la mujer can anita que estaba en su
propia tierra y que sin embargo jesús le
dice yo soy superior a ti y es ella la
que le enseña que en la migaja en el
fragmento ahí se encuentra el todo no en
toda la totalidad los estudios de género
en concreto los estudios queer le han
dado mucho la sociología la han
potenciado y le han dado un exponencial
político que es como evidente y es hasta
el lugar como pero el momento en que son
retomados reconocidos desde la teología
en el momento que lo aparentan hacia lo
religioso y para quienes no sean
explícitamente religiosos para el mundo
espiritual para el mundo la intuición de
la trascendencia incorporar la noción de
lo queer le aporta algo que les dice a
esta que le llamamos el ámbito de la fe
antropológica o fe religiosa la fe
antropológica que le aporta pues
primeramente lo sacude es la teología
queer es parece oxímoron y ccoo dentro
de los estudios de la religión
porque realmente lo que hace es
subvertir estas ideas de supremacía
recordemos que también los grandes
hechos de violencia en la historia han
sucedido a través de
luchas religiosas en el nombre de dios
la gente ha encarcelado ha torturado ha
violado y asesinado
entonces la teología queer lo que hace
es revertir ese orden subvertir ese
orden y hablar de un dios que es otro un
dios que no es el todopoderoso sino es
el dios que está que es vulnerable que
se encarna en los más vulnerables y que
se pone del lado de los otros realmente
que se pone del otro lado de la frontera
en estos tiempos desde el break sheet
hasta trump vemos que se habla acerca de
construir muros
a protegernos para dividirnos los unos
de los otros y sin embargo aquí lo que
el mensaje de la teología queer es
construir puentes de qué manera
destruimos estos muros para estar en
contacto con aquellos que son más
vulnerables entonces la teología queer
es muy importante para primero
intra de la propia teología de las
propias religiones para sacudir estos
sentidos de supremacía de patriarcado de
aplastamiento que ha habido durante
tantos siglos y luego para curar aquí el
mensaje de este de este pasaje
evangélico no es únicamente de construir
estas actitudes supremacistas sino que
también es un mensaje de sanación de qué
manera nosotros podemos sanar aquellas
heridas que tenemos y de qué manera
podemos encontrar en el otro en el que
es más vulnerable también el rostro de
dios
cada uno de los que estamos aquí habrá
experimentado al ver esta pequeña
muestra de tu trabajo pues lo que cada
que el experimento y le habrá comunicado
y le habrán nutrido pues aquello que le
habrá comunicado y nutrido pero no
quiero terminar esta conversación sin
preguntarte qué te pasa a ti cuando
danzas esto pues es un sentido como de
trance es meterse dentro del personaje
yo hice todo un ejercicio acerca de
donde sucede en el cuerpo cuando eres
humillado cuando eres discriminado
cuando eres estigmatizado por los demás
qué pasa a nivel corporal muchas veces
racionalizamos las cosas y actualmente
en la filosofía y el pensamiento que le
llaman posmoderno ha habido lo que se
llama el giro del cuerpo entonces es una
forma de hablar acerca de la importancia
del cuerpo en la constitución del tejido
social y de los individuos entonces aquí
es no solamente hablar sobre el cuerpo
sino habla más bien desde el cuerpo no
solamente hablar sobre la danza sino
desde la danza entonces eso requiere un
ejercicio no únicamente técnico físico
que es bastante fuerte sino también un
ejercicio emocional afectivo
y es tras dejarse transformar ponerse en
el lugar del otro y a partir de eso
empezar a ir subiendo es un movimiento
en toda la geografía se va haciendo un
movimiento ascendente de ir desde lo más
descendente hasta lo más ascendente es
ella la que toca a dios o la que es
tocada por dios quizás es ella la que
encarna el rostro de dios y finalmente
jesús descubre en ella la presencia de
dios entonces hacerlo corporalmente es
un ejercicio que me lleva un no
únicamente a nivel intelectual de
pensamiento racional sino también desde
el corazón desde las vísceras desde el
cuerpo mismo ángel méndez montoya
[Aplausos]